Samsung's Galaxy s 20 series of
smartphones has just been revealed at
their unpacked event but they left a lot
of very important information out of
their presentation things that could
actually make or break your decision to
buy one of these expensive phones now it
may seem like a lot of these are
negatives and that's because it makes
sense for a company to mention all of
the positives they possibly can but we
do have a few great things in this list
that weren't mentioned at the event so
let's get right into the 10 things
Samsung didn't mention first off a major
feature of the S 20 series of phones is
the 120 Hertz display which allows for
superfluid animations and a pretty
awesome advantage for gaming however
what they didn't mention was that once
when he Hertz is disabled by default and
when you do enable it the resolution
drops from the super crisp 1440p that
Samsung users love down to 1080p this
means you're only getting around 365
pixels per inch on the s20 ultras
massive 6.9 inch display it's not that
big of a deal but it might be a bit
deceiving when you see 1440p resolution
and once when he hurts on the same spec
sheet now the second thing that samsung
didn't mention is that although the S 20
and s 20 plus can shoot 8k resolution
video you can only shoot it with the
three x telephoto lens that's because
the main and ultra wide lenses only
feature 12 megapixel sensors in to shoot
a que you need at least a 33 megapixel
sensor now I'm not sure about you but I
don't use the telephoto lens for video
too often since it can be a little too
zoomed in even at 2 X so a 3 X telephoto
will be very limiting the s20 ultra does
get a hundred and eight megapixels on
the main lens so a K will be great on
that phone but another downside is that
tracking autofocus and other video
features are disabled here's a positive
thing they left out here in the States
the S 20 series uses the new snapdragon
865 processor which features a new GPU
that should be around 20 to 25 percent
faster for things like gaming as well as
a new AI engine that has over double the
performance the processor performance
itself should be improved as well as you
can see in this geekman chart Samsung
put a
huge emphasis on the crazy 100x space
zoom lens on the s20 ultra but it's
actually a bit deceiving a lot of people
are being led to believe that it's an
actual 10x optical lens that can zoom up
to 100 X but it's actually not
Sampson calls it a 10x hybrid optical
lens which means it combines optical
zoom digital zoom software and pixel
binning to get 10x the actual optical
zoom is only 4x just 2 times more zoomed
in than a regular 2x telephoto lens the
rest of the zoom up to 100x is mostly
advanced digital zoom and sharpening the
benefit of this lens is that it uses a
48 megapixel sensor with pixel binning
to churn out 12 megapixel photos with
better low-light in more detail however
what they don't mention is that this
lens's aperture is f 3.6 which means
that it naturally takes in 4 times less
light than the main F 1.8 aperture lens
so some of the benefits of pixel binning
are canceled out by the lower aperture
now on to the fifth thing that Samsung
didn't mention the 3x telephoto zoom
lens on the s 20 and s 20 plus are also
not actually 3x optical zoom but only 2
at zoom just like the regular telephoto
lens on the S 10 they add software in
digital zoom to make it a 3x hybrid zoom
lens so while it may still look sharper
than a 2x zoom lens cropped in just be
aware that it's not true 3x optical zoom
on a positive note the selfie camera on
the s20 ultra gets a 40 megapixel sensor
which gets pixel binned
into a 10 megapixel photo this should
add a lot of detail and sharpness to
selfies and since the aperture is a
pretty solid F 2.2 low-light selfies
should look pretty good as well so far
the s 20 ultra is looking like it's
actually worth the extra cash over the
other s 20s now on to number 7 Samsung
advertises that every s20 phone in the
series is packin 5g but there are
multiple types of 5g and not all of them
support the same version of it the S 20
ultra is the only one that actually
supports true millimeter wave 5g the s
20 only supports sub 6 5g which mainly
improve
reception penetrating buildings better
than others while the millimeter wave
frequency band greatly improves speed so
keep that in mind if you live in a city
that offers millimeter wave so that you
don't accidentally buy the cheaper
models and get disappointed by slower
than expected speeds for the a thing
Samsung did mention that the display is
getting upgraded to include 240 Hertz
touch sensitivity but they didn't
mention that it should also be 240 Hertz
even if you're using it in 60 Hertz mode
so if you aren't a big fan if once when
he hurts refresh rate and you'd rather
have 1440p resolution you're gonna be
gaining from the 240 Hertz touch
sensitivity and your phone should
actually feel a lot more responsive
compared to previous Samsung phones and
even iPhones which is a nice bonus
here's another very interesting thing
that Samsung didn't mention all of the
s20 phones feature in ultra wide lens
just like they did on previous phones
however the megapixels of the ultra wide
lens
went from 16 megapixels down to 12 when
we compared the ultra wide lens on the
note 10 to Apple's iPhone 11 pro the
notes ultra wide photos looked
noticeably sharper because of the extra
megapixels but now the detail should
actually be going down to match the
detail of the 11pro zalta wide lens now
answer the last one on the list the s20
ultra is one hundred and eight megapixel
camera sounds great but it may actually
reduce quality in a couple of ways the
pixel binning from 108 megapixels down
to a 12 megapixel photo will help with
detail sharpness and low-light but what
they don't tell you is that this process
is going to be a lot harder on the CPU
having to process nine times more data
than with a regular 12 megapixel photo
and since HDR photos take up to 10
images and combine them it's gonna make
it even harder to process multiple 108
megapixel photos this could end up
lowering the quality of HDR photos an
add extra shutter lag and as a final
bonus thing that they didn't mention the
headphone jack is finally gone on the S
20 series of phones probably because of
the new Galaxy buds plus truly wireless
earbuds we actually made a video
comparing those new ones to the old
models to see if it's worth upgrading so
if you haven't seen that
you can check it out by clicking right
over there and if you enjoy this video
tap the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]